capitaine il a vraiment combien de temps
ces voleurs vont-ils rester à bord ça
fait peut-être fait que préparer les
sacs et calamars ici mais sachez qu'au
pays tout le monde m'appelait la
première
à partir de maintenant j'ai une nouvelle
règle il n'y aurait que des pirates je
suis un pirate monsieur le puits quand
et là ça fait bien une semaine foot - le
creusot crois que c'est la carte aux
trésors du général
aquitaine il faut y aller vous pouvez
larguer les lois
[Applaudissements]
il existait un trésor caché quelque part
est marié vous en emparer vous avez tué
vos hommes de vos propres mains c'est ça
la guerre et je veux la gagner
ce sera ma coopérative ne peut y avoir
qu'un seul capital
ou est-ce que j'en étais pas
c'est ça la vraie carte aux trésors et
qu'il dise seul jeu parmi les plus
dangereux
alors tu comptes à nouveau me voler ce
qui me revient
[Musique]
alors y'a prévenir un trésor où on est
des maliens
rien d'étrange à l'ong viasna